what'd you just do armando took me for a
ride it's tesla and i just bought one
like literally four seconds ago
we're going to get it now she got the
plaid model s that's it she got the
plaid model s
congrats
[Music]
did i do it already is it doing it now
i just gave her my referral code
this might happen
it may not actually happen right the
second but we may be going to san diego
okay existing inventory is what we're
doing i think it went away wait what's
that what's the zip code yes here it is
here it is okay okay okay okay okay okay
okay oh my gosh i'm shaking i'm so
nervous right now i can't believe you
did this to me
i can't actually this is what i want
right this is it that is what you have
dude that is why i'm dude
i'm shaking
oh no i don't have an apple cart
attached to it
no hold on a second like oh my god my
heart rate what's gonna happen um
um are you actually doing this or you're
processing what
it's okay it went through
oh my god
so we're in the car on the way to the
dealership
you took me for one ride and here we are
here we go
and now the car is driving us to the
dealership so that you can go pick up
your plaid model s house look at this
the little cars look like little
marshmallows on the street
[Music]
you can buy a car on a phone and use
apple and use apple pay
is absurd
i love it
[Music]
okay i have to go to the bathroom before
we do anything we need masks
masks
hello
do you have a restroom
[Music]
oh man
this is so cool
no the cream looks actually so good and
okay here's the thing i was actually a
little bit worried because i don't i'm
not a huge fan of uh like wood interiors
so i thought this might have had it and
guess what it's not it's the carbon
fiber i'm so excited
what do you think of the steering wheel
okay i am really excited i'm going to
start crying
oh my gosh i'm so happy i'm really
excited like i was like excited like on
the way here but like this is so cool
i'm so
freaking excited the cream looks so good
this is so much better i didn't i'm not
gonna lie i didn't really know what i
was getting
and i'm so i'm like extra happy oh my
gosh and look at the little key and it's
like
is that pink that's pink oh my god they
belong
what do i do now
you're just going to fall onto the
steering wheel i just go fast just push
it wait just for it whenever you're
right now yeah right now
oh my god
bro comparing it to your tesla what does
that feel like oh dude like a rocket
dude i didn't even i don't even think i
pushed it down that far i don't think
you went fine i don't do it full no i
did it i was scared the only way to go
is that i'm having a wild day right now
i still can't believe this is all
working out
and the car's already yours you already
did your paperwork oh my gosh ready i'm
gonna put it all the way down is that
okay i can do that yeah it's great you
sure yep watch out for that
oh my god
what the heck
whoa
is that all of it i mean for a second it
was all the way down
ready ready ready ready that's all the
way that's all the way i think i'm gonna
block out
holy
god my body does not feel like it's it
feels like it's in space right now i i i
taste blood
it tastes blessed i definitely
my heart exploded it's straight up yeah
can i ask you a question yeah so uh you
guys saw how fast this purchase was made
in the office have you ever seen a
purchase made that fast
no i personally have not seen a purchase
that fast that's it was pretty
ridiculous when i was like i heard about
i was like wait what and you guys showed
up and i was like no way and then we got
it all done the paperwork done what two
minutes i mean i think this whole
process was maybe four hours and it was
that one only because it took us two
hours to drive here i mean like can you
think of any other like automaker that
does that's insane no i can't think of
another person that does this
she's insane no i definitely it's cool
i'm shaking so bad like this is wild i'm
already used to the sandwich driving
stick wheel look this is my first time
backing up oh yeah there you go this is
monumental look at that nice view yeah
how was your first super charging
experience it was great i had a lovely
time i had panera two times today and i
bought a car and everything is awesome
dude it's so freaking fast
like my brain still feels scrambled
check out cinematic tesla mode
[Music]
and then there's a button here okay so
you want to do is bring it as close as
possible to your charge port and then
push the button right here
just push the button
push it
oh my god yeah
and then just plug it in that's it does
it give me more slack you might have to
back up a little bit
that was cool as you got out the car
actually lifted up after you have to go
that close oh
thank you for joining this adventure
this was completely unexpected not
something we planned on doing today but
it happened and i'm so happy we love the
impulsive nature well congratulations
again so happy for you
do you have your seatbelt yeah firmly
press the brake with my left foot and
then i'm gonna accelerate preparing to
launch yeah
wait wait wait um what does it say right
so just let's go oh my god
i have to i have to i can't i had to
pull off because i almost freaking
blacked out
[Music]